[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم وتقبل الله صومكم اهلا بكم
في حصاد الليله معكم محمد الكريشان في هذه
اللحظات مدن وعواصم في العالم تعيش على
وقع احداث هامه هذه اللقطات من شوارع
مدينه الفرنسيه التي تشهد مع مدن اخرى
عوده للتظاهرات والاحتجاجات بعد اقرار
المجلس الدستوري قانون رفع سن التقاعد
هذه اللقطات هذه المره من القدس
وباحات المسجد الاقصى مع صلاه التراويح
وكذلك من مكه المكرمه واجواء الحرم المكي
في شهر رمضان المبارك وصلاه التراويح كذلك
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد نشر الدعم السريع قوات بجوار مطار
مروي بالولايه الشماليه وحشد القوات
بالخرطوم ومدن اخرى اتصالات دوليه
واقليميه متسارعه لاحتواء التوتر سعيون
محلي لاقناع حمادي والبرهان بعقد لقاء لحل
الخلافات وقيادي في الدعم السريع يبدي
استعداد حميد الى الحوار ويؤكد ان الامور
في مروي تتجه الى التهدئه
في عمليه واسعه على مدار ثلاثه ايام اتمام
المرحله الاولى من تبادل اسرى بين الحكومه
اليمنيه وجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
باشراف الصليب الاحمر الدولي
319 اسيرا اطلق سراحهم نحو مطاري صنعاء
وعدن
[موسيقى]
والمبعوث الاممي يؤكد اهميه الحوار
والتسويات للدفع باتجاه حل سياسي شامل
[تصفيق]
مع استمرار المعارك اتهامات متبادله بشان
قصف اهداف مدنيه شرقيه اوكرانيا حديث روسي
مستمر عن استعداد اوكراني مكثف لبدء هجوم
مضاد بحشد الافراد والعتاد والذخائر وفي
مقابله مع الجزيره وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه يقول ان الطريق انهاء الحرب
على بلاده مرهونه بمزيد من الدعم
والعقوبات على روسيا
[تصفيق]
المجلس الدستوري الفرنسي يشعل الاحتجاجات
بعد اقرار اهم بنود قانون رفع سن التقاعد
المثير للجدل رئيسه الحكومه تصف القرار
بالوسطى على قاعده لا غالب ولا مغلوب
والفدراليه العامه للعمل تهدد مكرون بان
التصديق على القانون سيقابل بالاصرار على
سحبه قبل اي لقاء او حوار وتدعو الى يوم
للتعبئه
في لقاءنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم قضيه التسريب من
البنتاجوان وتفاعل هذه القضيه امريكيا
وعالميا فبعد تحديد هويه واعتقاله من قبل
الانبياء يمثل جاك في الشراء امام محكمه
فيدراليه في بوسطن ويواجه توهمنت تتعلق
بنشر وثائق السريه تمس الامن القومي فيما
تحاول الاداره الامريكيه تقييم حجم الضرر
جراء التسرب او التسريب عفوا المثير للجدل
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف سيؤثر هذا
التسريب على صوره الولايات المتحده
ومنظومتها الامنيه النتائج جاءت على النحو
التالي
28% صوت لصالح امكانيه اهتزاز صوره واشنطن
وتاثير هذه التسريبات سيكون على المدى
البعيد
17% قالوا انها ازمه عابره ولن تؤثر في
حين رجح خمسه وخمسون بالمئه ان يكون لهذه
التسريبات تاثير بسيط
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
فهنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
في تحالف الحريه والتغيير مجموعه الكتله
الديمقراطيه عبد العزيز عشر للجزيره قال
ان لجنه ثلاثيه تمكنت من اقناع كل من رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
القوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حميدتي
بالجلوس لحل الخلافات وقال قيادي في الدعم
السريع وعضو في فريق التفاوض ان حميدتي
ابلغ الوسطاء استعداده للجلوس والحوار من
اجل تجاوز الخلافات الراحنه واكد مصدر
قيادي في الدعم السريع للجزيره ان الامور
تتجه الى التهنئه بوعيده توتر الذي شاب
انتشار قوات الدعم السريع في في اطار اداء
مهامها بمنطقه مروي شمالي السودان ياتي
ذلك بينما تتكثف الاتصالات من اطراف دوليه
واقليميه ومحليه لاحتوائ هذا التوتر اثر
نشر الدعم السريع قوات بجوار مطار مروي
بالولايه الشماليه كما يتهم الجيش الدعم
السريع بحشد قواته ايضا في الخرطوم ومدن
اخرى
هذا وقد قال قائد الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشات
بمدينه مروي سليمان كمال حاج الخضر
للجزيره انهم فوجئوا بدخول قوات الدعم
السريع دون اي اخطار مسبق واضاف ان قوته
تعاملت مع تحركات قوات الدعم السريع
بمسؤوليه وحكمه حتى تجنب البلاد تاثيرات
تاثيرات اي مواجهات محتمله
وواصلنا معهم واستفسرنهم وافاظون بانه ما
عندهم
اختار او تنسيق مسبق مع القوات المتحركه
وهي بالتحديد القوات الدعم السريع في
تحركات
الاجراءات اللازمه مثل هكذا مواقف
لانه احنا عندنا في القوات المسلحه
حين اقوم هناك تحركات لافرادنا او وحداتنا
او تشكيلاتنا يكون هناك دائما يختار مسبق
وجب علينا ان ندقنا قوس الخطر هل هي بدايه
مرحله جديده يتشكل فيها المكون العسكري في
السودان
مهما كان الجواب الثابت انها ازمه جديده
يعيشها السودان بالاضافه لازماته المتعدده
المعقده منذ اجراءات الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر عام 2021 التي اتخذها البرهان
وجرها بموجبها حل الحكومه ومجلس السياده
السابق ظلت الخلافات بين الجيش بقياده
الرئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده نائبه
محمد حمدان دقلو تتطور منذ الخامس من
ديسمبر الماضي حينما تم توقيع اتفاق
ايطالي يؤسس لفتره الانتقاليه وكان دمج
جميع القوات بندا اساسيا فيه ايده الجيش
وعلى راسه البرهان بقوه وبلغت الخلافات
ذروتها بانسحاب ممثل الجيش من ورشه
الاصلاح الامني العسكري اخيرا لعدم شمول
توصياتها على الجدوله الزمنيه لعمليه
الدمج التي نص عليها الاتفاق الايطالي
ومقترح تنفيذها بالتزامن مع الترتيبات
الامنيه للحركات المسلحه الموقع على اتفاق
جوبا سرعان ما شرعت قوات الدعم السريع
وبعد فتره وجيزه من ذلك في اعاده انتشارها
بصوره واسعه في مدينه مرور الاستراتيجيه
بشمال السودان وغيرها كما جابت كتائبها
شوارع العاصمه الخرطوم وهو اجراء قابله
الجيش بالمثل في الخرطوم ومروي وكل ارجاء
السودان
قوات الدعم السريع وصفه انتشارها بانه تم
وفق القانون وكانها تذكر البرهان بانه هو
من الغى من قبل في نهايه يوليو عام 2019
الماده الخامسه من قانون الدعم السريع
والتي تنص على خضوع هذه القوات لقانون
القوات المسلحه وكان البرلمان السوداني في
عهد الرئيس المعزول عمر حسن البشير قد
اجاد ذلك القانون وتقررت بموجبه تبعيه
قوات الدعم السريع للجيش السوداني
واحتكامها لقانون التسليح والتنظيم
والمحاسبه
التطورات الراهنه السودان في حاله بالغه
من التوتر بانتظار نتائج المنشدات
والوساطات من الداخل والخارج التي تحث
الطرفين على خفض التصعيد والدخول في حوار
لاحتواء الازمه
انضم الينا الان من الخرطوم كل من احمد
يحيى الباحث والمحلل السياسي والهند عز
الدين الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اهلا بهما
ابدا بالسيد احمد يحيى
هل فعلا الامور تتجه الان الى التهدئه
السلام عليكم
بكل خير ومساء النور وتحيه لهذا المشاهدين
اهلا وسهلا يضيفك الكريم صحيح ان الامور
الان تصير او تسير نحو التهدئه
بحكم ان هناك جلسات تمت ما بين الطرفين
طرفي المؤسسه العسكريه اللي هو السيده
البرهان والسيد محمد حمدانو ببساطه من
رجال يا
وطنيينهم الوطنيه بل هو باعتبار انهم
يسعون يعني لملمه اطراف القوه السودانيه
في هذه المرحله والمساهمه في استدباب
الامني والسلام والاستقرار وهما السيد مني
اركم الناوي رئيس حركه والسيد مالك عقال
هير والسيد جبريل وزير الماليه ورئيس حركه
عدل المساواه وانضم اليهما السيده عبد
الله علي مسار وهو معروف بشخصيته الوطنيه
والقويه والواضحه كما انضم عليهم السيد
نائم نائب حاكم اقليم دارفور السيد وهم
اصدروا بيان انهم جلسوا مع الطرف الاول
للسيد محمد حمدان هو توصل اليه او توصلوا
معه لبعض التفاهمات الاوليه التي تفضي
وتقضي الى عدم التصعيد في المجال الاعلامي
او غيره كما انه ايضا سيجلسون مع سيده
برهان
فيما تبقى من هذا اليوم وانا اعتقد هذا
الامر هو امر وطني وامر ضروري باعتبار ان
هذه
الازمه في تقديري هي ازمه عابره وقد تكون
جزء منها مصنوعه وهناك اطراف تسعى
للتطوير من هذه الازمه وضخه كثير من
المعلومات الغير صحيحه في الاسافير وغيرها
بحثا عن منازلهم في غضون هذه الازمه لكن
انا اؤكد
يعني هذا التقييم ربما نريد ان نعرف من
السيد هندي عز الدين ما اذا كان هذا
التقييم المتفائل هو من طرفي الازمه
نعم السلام عليكم احييكم احيي ضيفك الكريم
مشاهدي الجزيره اهلا اوضاع الان على ساحه
مروي هادئه
مستقره ولكن في نفس الوقت لا نستطيع ان
نجزم بان الامر قد انتهى بصوره حاسمه لانه
هنالك قوات خرجت من الخرطوم ومن وسط
السودان باتجاه مروي وصلت الى مروي هناك
قوات مسلحه اصلها الجيش السوداني موجود
بالقرب من قاعده مرري الجويه اضافه الى
تعزيزات جاءت من القوات المسلحه ايضا من
عطبره ومن مناطق في شمال السودان ويبقى
السؤال الاساسي صحيح ان هنالك وساطه من
القاعده الثلاثه الموقعين على اتفاقيه جبل
السلام ملك عقار ومني اركب الناوي وجبريل
ابراهيم ولكن يبقى السؤال عن ما هو الهدف
الذي تحركت به قوات الدعم السريع بنحو مئه
من السيارات المدجيه بالس نحو قاعده مروي
الجويه يعني قياده الدعم السريع واعلامها
لم يوضح بعد ما هي المهمه التي خرجت بها
هذه القوات ناحيه شمال السودان خاصه اذا
كان معلوم بالاعراف العسكريه والقانون انه
لا بد من اخذ اذن من قياده القوات المسلحه
السودانيه البيان الاول للدعم السريع
يتحدث عن ان حركتهم بعلم ومعرفه قياده
القوات المسلحه السودانيه ولكن فوجئنا
سريعا بان الجيش نفى ذلك وقال ان هذه
القوات تحركت دون اذننا ودون علمنا وهذا
يعرض الامن والسلامه في السودان للخطر حتى
الان نحن لا نعرف ما هي الوجهه وما هي
الغرض من هذه المهمه في ذهاب نحو 100 عربه
مدججه بالمدفعيه الى قاعده جويه تتبع
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه هل معنى ذلك يا
سيد احمد يحيى بان
مؤشرات التهدئه على اهميتها تحتاج الى مثل
هذا التوضي ح الذي يتحدث عنه السيد عز
الدين
في تقديري ان المؤسسه العسكريه هي مؤسسه
متكامله وهموم يعلمون تماما شكل الاجراءات
الداخليه المتعلقه بالتحركات وبالتسليح
وغيره وحاذر امر غير خاضع لمعرفه
المواطنين هو امره عسكري بحثي يخضع يعني
الاشياء الداخليه لكن كثير من الذين
يسيرون الاشياء في الاسافير قد تكون ليست
لديهم معلومات دقيقه باعتبار ان هذا الامر
هو امر عسكري بحث لا يمكن لقوه هي متحركه
ان تعلم الشعب السوداني كله انها لديها
امر تحرك ومتجه الى مكان ما قوات الدعم
الشريحه قوات متواجده في قصر الجمهوري
متواجده في كثير جدا حتى في منزل السيد
البرهان متواجدين متواجدين في اقصى
الجنينه واقصى بورسودان شرقا متواجدين في
اغلق ولايات السودان لا نعلم بشكل
تحركاتهم الداخليه ولا نعلم نواياهم بل
انما هم مؤسسه تتبع للقوات المسلحه
وانشاتها القوات المسلحه او المسؤوله عن
القوات المسلحه فبالتالي انا في تقديري
على الق هتتحمل مسؤولياتها في اطار
السيطره والتحكم في هذه القوات وعمل
اجراءات داخليه تضمن شكل التنسيق الكبير
في المجال الامني والمجال العسكري حتى لا
يدخل المواطنين في رعب هذا الامر لا يخص
المواطنين كثيرا شكل التحرك الغير يعني
يعني يرونه غير قانون او غير ذلك انا
اعتقد هذا الامر هو يخص المؤسسه العسكريه
وهي اجراءات نحن نرى كثير من من الارتال
العربات العسكريه تحوم وتجوب السودان ولا
نعلم كيف تحوم هنا نعلم ما هي متحرك ولكن
اهميه هذه التفاصيل نريد ان نعرف النهايه
سيد هندي عز الدين اذا سيرنا هذا التفاؤل
الحذر بامكانيه وصول الازمه الى النهايه
على اي اساس سيتم ذلك
طبعا انا اختلف مع ضيفك الكريم ان الامر
هم المواطنين اذا كانت قياده الجيش هي
التي خرجت وقالت ان هذه القوه
غادرت الخرطوم وغادرت مواقع عسكريه اخرى
من غير اذن القوات المسلحه اذا قياده
القوات المسلحه هي التي خرجت واعلنت بوضوح
ان هذا تجاوز للقانون ولم يعني يتبرع
المواطنين بهذا الحديث طبعا انا افتكر
الحل سيكون في اتجاه ان تنسحب هذه القوات
قوات الدعم السريع من مروي وان تنسحب ايضا
تعزيزات العسكريه التي جاءت من الجيش
لمواجهه هذه القوات
وان يعود الناس الى مائده الحوار هذه
التحركات العسكريه لن تسفر عن شيء باتجاه
الضغط
لحمل الجيش السوداني على التوقيع على
العمليه السياسيه اذا لم يكن هنالك توافق
كامل اذا لم تكن هناك الكتل المهمه التي
شاركت في بدايات العمليه السياسيه وما
زالت جيش يتحدث عن ضروره انضمام من كتله
الديموقراطيه على الاقل شكرا للاتفاق
الايطالي ليكون العمليه السياسيه عمليه
شامله ولذلك هذه العمليات العسكريه لن
تفيد كثيرا في ان تمارس ضغط على قياده
الجيش السوداني شكرا لك سيد هندي عز الدين
شكرا لك ايضا سيد احمد يحيى كنتما معنا من
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
انتهت في اليمن اليوم الاول من عمليه
تبادل للاسرى بين الحكومه اليمنيه وجماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين والتي تستمر ثلاثه
ايام حسب اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
وقد افاد مراسلنا ان برنامج اليوم الاول
لعمليه تبادل الاسرى انتهى باطلاق سراح
319 اسيرا من الجانبين وقد وصلت الى مطار
صنعاء رحلتان قادمتان من مطار عدن تقلان
250 اسيرا تابعين للحوثيين
استقبل اهالي بدوي الاسرى بفرحه عارمه حيث
اتى الكثير منهم الى مقربه الطائره
لاستقبال اسراهم هنا نشهد الدفعه الاولى
وهي 125
ووصولهم الى مطار صنعاء الدولي
واستقبلوا بحفاوه من قبل
اهاليهم وايضا بشكل رسمي
وينتظر ايضا الوصول 125 اخرين قادمين من
عدن فيما قد تم الترحيل اكثر من 30 اسيرا
الى مطار عدن الدولي تستمر تبادل صفقه
الاسراء ليكتمل العدد ما يقارب حسب تصريح
رئيس اللجنه الاسرى لانصار الحوثيين وهم
ما يقاربوا 69 اسيرا لطرف الحكومه الشرعيه
والمجلس الانتقالي
وسيستقبل ايضا انصار الله
ما يقارب
250 اسيرا معظم هذه الاسراء وهم ايضا تبع
من الصفقه التي تم
ابرامها في جنيف
وبجمالا ستكون 887 اسيرا طرف الحكومه
الشرعيه سيستقبل ما يقارب 107 تقريبا وفي
منحوثيين سيستقبلونها وانصار الله
سيستقبلون ما يقارب
708 اسير
مراسلنا ياسر حسن تابع وصول تسعه وستين من
الاسرى التابعين للحكومه اليمنيه في
دفعتين قادمين من مطار صنعاء بينهم وزير
الدفاع الاسبق اللواء محمود الصبيحي وشقيق
الرئيس السابق اللواء ناصر منصور هادي
نق
ف الدولي على متنها 35 من الاسرى التابعين
للحكومه الشرعيه وعلى راسهم وزير الدفاع
الاسبق محمود الصبيحي وكذلك ناصر منصور
هادي شقيق الرئيس اليمني السابق عبد ربه
منصور هادي هذه الرحله هي الرحله الاولى
القادمه من صنعاء وهناك رحله اخرى ايضا
يشرف عليها الصليب الاحمر الدولي ستصل
ايضا هذا اليوم وعلى متنها
35 او 34 من الاسرار التابعين للحكومه
اليمنيه قادمون من صنعاء ايضا قبل قرابه
ساعه انطلقت من هنا من مطار عدن الدولي
رحله طيران على متنها
125 من الاسرى التابعون او من الاسرى
التابعين لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ذهبوا الى صنعاء وايضا هناك رحله اخرى هذا
اليوم سيكون على متنها قرا
من الاسرى الحوثيين ايضا ستذهب الى صنعاء
ايضا بالمقابل هناك رحله اخرى ستاتي من
صنعاء على متنها اربعه وثلاثون من اسرى
الحكومه الشرعيه هذه الصفحه هي الاكبر في
تاريخ تبادل الاسرى بين الطرفين بين جماعه
انصار الله الحسين والحكومه الشرعيه
والتحالف من جهه اخرى قرابه
887 من الاسرى سيتم اطلاقهم من الطرفين في
هذه الصفقه التي تستمر على مدى ثلاثه ايام
ياسر حسن الجزيره عدن
فيما قال متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان مستشار الرئيس بايدن لشؤون
الشرق الاوسط
الامريكي للطاقه عموس والمبعوث الامريكي
لليمن تيموتي
ناقشوا مع ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان ومسؤولين سعوديين الجهود
المبذوله لانهاء الحرب في اليمن واضاف
المتحدث في بيان للجزيره ان ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين اكدوا الاهميه التي يليها
الرئيس بايدن لانهاء الصراع في اليمن وذكر
البيان ان المسؤولين الامريكيين اكدوا دعم
الولايات المتحده الدفاع عن المملكه
السعوديه ضد التهديدات من اليمن او اي
مكان اخر
تفاصيل اكثر عن عمليه التبادل هذه في
العرض التالي
ليست حركه طبيعيه في مطاري صنعاء وعدن في
اليمن
[موسيقى]
تحمل هذه الطائرات ما قد يعتبر اهم عمليه
تبادل للاسرى بين اطراف الحرب في البلاد
سنوات السجن انتهت لهؤلاء وبقي وراءهم
الاف ينتظرون
887 اسيرا هم صفقه تبادل بين الحكومه
وجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين استقبل
الحوثيون 250 اسيرا قدموا من مطار عدن الى
مطار صنعاء استقبلت الحكومه 70 اسيرا من
مطار صنعاء حطوا في مطار عدن من بين
السبعين وزير الدفاع السابق وشقيق الرئيس
السابق تتوسع عمليات التبادل لتشمل اسرى
ينتقلون في رحلات متزامنه بين مطارات
صنعاء والمخا في اليمن والرياض وابها في
السعوديه
371 اسيرا من الجانبين بالاضافه الى 16
اسيرا سعوديا وثلاثه سودانيين هذه الصفقه
الاهم التي تاتي بعد عام على الهدنه هدنه
انسانيه اطلقتها الامم في ابريل الماضي
شملت في ذلك الوقت فتح مطار صنعاء وفتحا
جزئيا لميناء الحديده الذين تسيطر عليهما
جماعه الحوثهم هدفت الامم المتحده حينها
لتخفيف الازمه الانسانيه في البلاد بعد
ثمان سنوات من القتال خلال العام الماضي
ايضا جرت بعض صفقات التبادل الصغيره بين
اطراف الازمه وقبل ذلك عام 2020 جرت اكبر
عمليه تبادل للاسرى حتى الان شملت قرابه
1400 اسير من الاطراف ليبقى الاف الاسراف
الانتظار ملف الاسرى لم يكن الا عقده صعبه
في حوارات الحل لكن الازمه في اليمن اكثر
تعقيدا وتفصيلا ينظر الجميع بعين التفاؤل
الى التوافقات الاقليميه في حلحله عقد
الازمه في اليمن هكذا تتحرك الازمه
اليمنيه نحو الحل شيئا فشيئا او هكذا يرى
اطراف النزاع والى حين الانتهاء من ملف
تبادل الاسرى يبقى اعلان السلام الشامل في
اليمن املا ينتظره ملايين المتضررين
معنى الروحاني المدير التنفيذي لسياسات
والشراكات في مركز صنعاء للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك هل يمكن ان
يكون ما جرى مجرد بدايه لعمليات تبادل
اخرى في المستقبل
هو بالتاكيد ما حدث اليوم هو ان تراجع
انسانيه وهي بادئه لتبادل اسرار في اطار
الاتفاق الاخير في جنيف والذي كان الاتفاق
على تبادل ما يقارب من 223 اسيرا
823 من قبل الحكومه المعترف بها شرعيه
وايضا 1400 تاثير
للحوثين ولكن
ملف مثل هذه الملفات والذي يعتبر بكلفه
منخفضه سياسيا واثر انساني كبير ما زال
مازال محل خلاف ولا ولم نصل الى مرحله ان
تعقد صفقه مقابل الكل مقابل الكل ما بين
الطرفين وهذا النوع من التعقيد في هذا
الملف او التسييس لهذا الملف يعكس مستوى
عالي من مسؤوليه من قبل الطرفين هذا
الاتفاق التي تم عليه او ما نراها اليوم
التبادل اسرع هو اتفاق تم الاتفاق عليه في
مارس من العام الماضي
ولكن تم التوقيع على هذه الاسماء تحديدا
كلفتها كثيرا الاسرى بشكل مباشر وكذلك اسر
هذه الاسرع هذا الملف وان كان كما اشرت
اقل كلفه سياسيه ولكنه يعكس ايضا ان
الاطراف اليوم ليست مستعده ان تخطو خطوات
جديه تجاه الملفات الاخرى المتعلقه بعمليه
السلام والتي هي اكثر تعقيدا ولها ايضا
كلفه سياسيه اكبر ولكن اجواء التفاؤل كما
هو واضح من خلال التصريحات هل تشيء بجدول
سريعه لدفعات اخرى في القريب
هذه الدفعات كما اشرت هي دفعات في اطار
الاتفاق الاخيره الذي حدث في الشهر الماضي
وكما اشرت عددهم 223 وستحدث خلال الايام
المقبله وايضا سابعه المقبله الافراج عن
هذا العدد فقط ولكن هناك عدد اكبر بكثير
من الاسرار لدى الطرفين ما زال لم يتم
الحديث عنهم او الاتفاق عنهم او حتى الخوض
كما اشرت في صفقه تبادل الكل مقابل الكل
وهذا لم يحدث حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن لا يمكن
ان نتهاون بما حدث اليوم بالعكس هذه
الاجواء الايجابيه وهذا النوع من التبادل
اسرع وهام جدا ولكن يتوقع ايضا من الاطراف
ان تتحمل مسؤوليه اكبر في الافراج عن بقيه
الاسرى وايضا التخفيف من هذا المعاناه
الانسانيه لدى الاسرى واسرهم في عموم
اليمن هذا التفاؤل ايضا هل هل يمكن ما
اشرت اليه قبل قليل من عدم تفاؤل بتسويه
كامله الا تعتقد بان الجو الحالي خاصه
الانفراج بين السعوديه وايران ستسرع من
وتيره التواصل الى تسويه كامله في القريب
للاسف فاذا راينا المحادثات السعوديه
الحوتيه التي جرت في الايام الماضيه لم
تحقق اي تقدم حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال
الحوثيون حتى لحظه ينظرون الى ان
المحادثات يجب ان تقتصر فقط على
الملفات الانسانيه ولا تقتصر عن البحث في
ايجاد حل سلام شامل او الخوض في مباحثات
تتحدث عن مراحل مختلفه كما
تخللت
العرض الذي قدم من قبل السعوديه ان يكون
هناك انفراجه انسانيه بدرجه اولى ثم نتحول
الى مرحله انتقاليه يتم الحديث عن مباحثه
سياسيه يبدو ان
المضي حول هذا الجانب ما زال محدودا جدا
لم يكن هناك اي تفاعل ايجابي نتحدث الان
عن جوله اخرى كان متوقع على الاقل ان يحدث
نوع من الاتفاق في هذه الايام ولكن يبدو
انه هناك ستحدث جوله اخرى ولكن لا اتوقع
حتى اللحظه ان المناخ مهيا للوصول لحل
سلام شامل في هذه الايام او فيها هذه
المرحله القادمه
انصح التعبير شكرا لك اسامه الروحاني من
اوكسفورد
[موسيقى]
قالت الان الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
حيث قالت السلطات المحليه في دونيتسك ان
اربعه اشخاص قتلوا واصيب عشره في قصف
للقوات الاوكرانيه استهدف مدينه ياسين
وفي مدينه سلافيان الشرقيه البلاد افادت
السلطات الاوكرانيه بمقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
واصابه 21 في قصف روسي قالت انه استهدف
مناطق سكنيه في المدينه وقد بث الرئيس
الاوكراني عبر حسابه على تيليجرام مقطعا
مصورا قال انه للقصف الذي طال المدينه
واصفا اياه بالوحشيه
طلبوا رباره العسكريه الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تكثف استعدادته استعداداتها
لبدء ما سماه هجوم الربيع والصيف بحشد
الافراد والعتاد والدقائر واضاف الموقع ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تعد لهجوم شامل على طول
خط الجبهه واشار الموقع كذلك الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تناور للتعميه على
المواقع الرئيسيه التي سينطلق منها الهجوم
بانشائها نقاط تجمعا هجوميه كاذبه
قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
ديمتروكوليبا في مقابله مع الجزيره تبث
كامله في وقت لاحق ان من يريد انهاء الحرب
على بلاده عليه ان يزيد الدعم ويفرض
المزيد من العقوبات على روسيا واكد كوليبا
ان علاقاتي بلاده مع الولايات المتحده
مبنيه على الثقه مضيفا انهم يسعون لتحويل
مشكله تسريب الوثائق الى فرصه لتسريع
الحصول على الاسلحه المطلوبه واضاف كوليبا
ان توقيت الهجوم المضاد يتاثر طرديا بسرعه
وصول الدعم الى بلادها
على الفشل والحياه لم تعلمه اي درس لذا
فهو مستمر بالفشل اوكرانيا لديها القدره
على الانتصار في الحرب واستعاده وحده
اراضيها ادعو الدول الصديقه التي التزمت
الحياد ان تساعد اوكرانيا في تحقيق
اهدافها بدلا من التفكير بخيارات اخرى
الاطراف التي تشكك بقدره اوكرانيا على
الانتصار في الحرب هي نفس الاطراف التي
اعتقدت ان اوكرانيا لن تص مد اكثر من عشره
ايام اذا غازتها روسيا
وكان موقع قد نقل عن مسؤولين اوروبيين
المطلعين ان حلفاء اوكرانيا يقللون من
توقعاتهم بشان الهجوم المقبل وان هناك
حاجه الى قتال مكثف حتى العام المقبل لخلق
ظروف ميدانيه افضل واشار الموقع الى ان
الحلفاء يشككون بشكل متزايد في قدره الجيش
الاوكراني على تحقيق اختراق هذا العام
وقال ان الهدف الاكثر واقعيه هو تحقيق
القوات الاوكرانيه تقدما بمسافه 30
كيلومترا لاستهداف خطوط الامداد الروسيه
بالمدفعيه ونقل الموقع عن مسؤولين عسكريين
اوروبيين انه من المتوقع ان يبدا الهجوم
الاوكراني بحلول منتصف الشهر المقبل وعلى
محاور عده
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا اقر المجلس الدستوري بنودا في
قانون اصلاح التقاعد من بينها رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 كما رفض تنظيم
استفتاء لاقرار الاصلاحات على القانون
وبعد تصديق المجلس الدستوري يصبح الطريق
سالكا امام الرئيس
لاصدار القانون لكن النقابات طالبته بعدم
فعل ذلك متوعده بمواصله الاحتجاج وقد خرجت
مظاهرات في مدن فرنسيه عده رفع فيها
المحتجون شعارات مندده بهذا القانون
ومتواعده بمواصله الاحتجاج حتى اسقاطها
هذا وقد قالت الامينه العامه للفدراليه
الفرنسيه للعمل انه اذا صدق ماكرون على
القانون الجديد فانه لن يتم اي لقاء معه
الا لبحث سحب هذا القانون من جهتها قالت
رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه انه لا غالب ولا
مغلوب في هذا المسار الدستوري وق بيل صدور
القرار كان رئيس ماكرون قد وجه دعوه
للنقبات العماليه للحوار يوم الثلاثاء لكن
النقابات رفضت الدعوه وشددت على انه لا
حواره قبل الاول من مايو ايار حيث يتوقع
ان يتحول عيد العمال العالمي الى يوم
للتعبئه والاحتجاج ضد هذا القانون
ينضم الينا الان من باريس برونو الباحث في
مركز البحوث السياسيه اهلا وسهلا بك
الان كيف تبدو الصوره بعد كل الذي حدث
اليوم
اجتيازه مرحله مهمه جدا بالنسبه للسلطه
التنفيذيه والايمان والمقران ان المجلس
الدستوري وافق على الاجراء الاهم شيء الا
وهو ان يكون عمر التقاعد 64 سنه ويبدو
الان اصبح من السهل على السلطه التنفيذيه
تنفيذ ذلك كما وهذا لن نكن عليه الحال قبل
يومين لكن السياسه الوضعيه الوضع والعلاقه
بين السلطه التنفيذيه والنقابات تبدو
متوتره ومهمه خاصه لان
النقابات تلقت رد فعل سيء جدا
والجمهور خرج الى الشوارع في كثير من
المدن للتعبير عن استيائهم عن قرار مجلس
الدستوري خروج الجمهور تحديدا جعل البعض
يطرح الشرعيه الدستوريه مقابل الشرعيه
شرعيه الشارع هل ستستمر هذه الاشكاليه
نعم فعلا انك محقق لان هذه النقطه الاكثر
اهميه في كل هذه الازمه التي نعيشها حاليا
في فرنسا فهناك نوع من
النزاع ما بين
الجوانب الشرعيه وغير الشرعيه فهناكرون
سلطه التنفيذيه الذي يقول ان انتخبت من
الشعب عندما تحدث عن اصلاحاته هو شرح هو
شرح اثناء حملات انتخابيه انهم كان يدعوا
هذه
الاصلاحات قال لانكم انتخبتموني وانا اطبق
شيئا كنت قد تحدثت عنه ثم هناك مساله
شرعيه
حريه التعبير التعبير الناس وعن طريق
المواطنين والنقابات وهذا يعني هو السبب
هذا التوتر الديمقراطي في فرنسا هناك
نوعين مختلفين من الشرعيه احدهما ضد الاخر
شكرا جزيلا لك برونو كونتريس من باريس
في العرض التالي نتعرف على ابرز
الاعتراضات على تعديل قانون التقاعد في
فرنسا ولماذا يثير هذه الردود الغاضبه
ينص التعديل القانون على رفع سن التقاعد
من 62 الى 64 عاما تدريجيا وصولا لعام
2030 وزياده مده الاشتراكات المطلوبه في
الضمان الاجتماعي من 42 الى ثلاثه واربعين
عاما لكي يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه كاملا
اتفقت النقابات على رفض التعديل لكن المهن
الاكثر تضررا هي تلك التي يستفيد العاملون
فيها من التقاعد المبكر مثل عمال السكك
الحديديه وسائقي القطارات حيث سيتم توحيد
التقاعد في نظام واحد قائم على النقاط
ويخشى العمال انه بموجب نظام التقاعد
الجديد سيتعين عليهم العمل لفتره اطول
وزياده الاقتطاعات من رواتبهم اما الحكومه
فترى في النظام الجديد محاوله لجعل نظام
المعاش التقاعدي قابلا للاستمرار وتوفير
قرابه تسعه عشر مليار دولار من ميزانيه
الدوله سنويا
وتنفق فرنسا بحسب اركان رسميه قرابه 14%
من الناتج المحلي على برنامج التقاعد
مقابل 57
في الولايات المتحده وعشره واربعه اعشار
في المئه في المانيا لكن معدلات الضرائب
في فرنسا تعتبر من الاعلى اوروبيا ولهذا
اقترحت النقابات بدائل على الحكومه تتركز
حول فرض ضرائب عادله على الاثرياء ورفع
مساهمه ارباب العمل في صناديق التقاعد وهو
ما ترفضه الحكومه
[موسيقى]
مثلا جاك دي شراء المشتبه بتسريبه وثائقه
ومعلومات سريه من الفانتاجون امام محكمه
فيدراليه في ولايه ماسه لتوجه له تهمه تحت
مظله قانون التجسس هذا وقد قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انه وجه المجتمع
العسكري والاستخباراتي في بلاده لاتخاذ
خطوات لمزيد من التامين والحد من توزيع
المعلومات الحساسه مشيرا الى ان فريقا من
الامن القومي يقوم حاليا بالتنسيق مع
شركاء الولايات المتحده وحلفائها من جهته
قلن المتحدث
ان الوثائق التي سربت حساسه وانما حدث يعد
جريمه متعمده
متهمه بتسريب معلومات سريه امام قادن
فيدرالي في مدينه بوسطن وجهت له تهمه
الاولى حفظ ونشر دون اذن المعلومات مرتبطه
بالامن القومي والثانيه ازاله وحفظ دون
اذن وثائق سريه ديشار البالغ من العمر 21
عاما
ظهر في المحكمه مكبلا بالاصفاظ برفقه محام
عينه المحكمه وبحضور والديه اللذين لم
يجيبا على اسئله الصحفيين المتجمعين خارج
المحكمه
سيتم اتهام جاكي شيرا بموجب قانون التجسس
والذي يقضي بشكل اساسي ان المستندات
السريه اذا اخذت بشكل خاطئ او اذا فقدت او
سلمت او احتفظ بها فهي جريمه فيدراليه
بموجب قانون التجسس
الشكوى الجنائيه التي نشرت تزامنا مع
اتهام دشاره عن تفاصيل باتت معروفه بشان
تسريبه معلومات ووثائق سريه عبر مجموعه
تواصل على منصه ديسكورد كما تكشف عن انه
حاول بعد الكشف عن التسريبات البحث في
سجلات سريه عما اذا كانت عرفت هويته في
المحكمه اخبر تشيرا انه قد يواجه في حال
الادانه عقوبه تبلغ 15 عاما بالسجن بينما
تستمر في واشنطن تفاعلات هذه القضيه التي
وضعت الاداره الامريكيه في موقف محرج مع
الحلفاء قبل الخصوم وزير العدل الامريكي
بدوره شدد على ان وزاره الدفاع تقود جهدا
لتقييم ومراجعه تداعيات التسريبات على
الامن القومي
وزاره الدفاع تقود حاليا جهدا مهما لتقييم
ومراجعه تداعيات الامن القومي بالاضافه
الى اجراء مراجعه لاساليب الوصول الى
المعلومات والمحاسبه واجراءات الرقابه
التي تتبعها الوزاره حتى لا يحدث امر
مشابه مره اخرى
للتحقيق والرد على تسريب الوثائق تواجه
ادارته اسئله من المشرعين تتعلق بحيثيات
ما حدث وعدم دراسه التسريبات قبل فوات
الاوان بسبب كويك الجزيره بوسطن
وينضم الينا من باريس جيم تاون نائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه سبق اهلا وسهلا بك
ما ابرز الدروس المستفاده لحد الان من هذه
القضيه
الدروس هي ان علينا ان نؤدي عملا افضل ما
يتعلق بالتصاريح الامنيه وعلى انه احسن
عملنا فيما يتعلق الوصول الى معلومات سريه
للغايه هذا هو جزء من عمليه تسمى فقط عند
الحاجه للمعرفه اي بانقناك الحاجه
لا يمكن وصولها وهذا
الجندي او العسكري في القوه الجويه لابد
انه لم يكن لديه حاجه ليعرف كل هذه
المعلومات والتي يستعمل الوصول اليها
وبالتالي اعتقد ان سواء كانت في القوه
الجويه او وزاره الدفاع نفسها عليهم ان
يشدد الاجراءات من يحصل على المعلومات من
يصل عليها ومن يحصل على التصريح الامني
بذلك طبعا هناك مشاكل حكم في يتعلق بهذا
الشاب ومع الاسف انه لم يفهم ذلك اثناء
اعطائه او دراسه وتحلي له مساله منحى
تصريح الامنيه وبالتالي فالنظام بحاجه
لتعديل كما جاء في الوكالات سيد هذا الشاب
التحق بعمله عام 2019 بمعنى ان عمره انذاك
كان 17 عاما او 18 عاما اليس من باب
السهوله كامله ان تعهد الى شاب في هذا
العمر وثائق بهذه الحساسيه
ان المشكله كانت هي مساله الوصول
للمعلومات لا ما اعتقد انه اعطيت له
مسؤوليات عن الوثائق انفسها ليبدو انه
كانت تقنيا وانه كان مسؤولا عن التاكد من
المعدات والكمبيوترات تعمل بشكل جيد لكن
ضمن مهنته وعمله كان يستطيع ان يدخل الى
قواعد بيانات وان يصل الى
مواقع اخرى في النظام المحمي
وبالتالي يطلع على وثائق رغم انه لم يكن
هناك حاجه للطلائع عليها هذا هو الشيء
المهم هنا لو لم يكن لديه حاجه للاطلاع
عليها وبعد ذلك يستطيع الوصول الى بعض
المواقع في هذه الكمبيوترات الامنه
للاستخبارات
يستطيع الدخول اليها وبالتالي كان لابد من
اكتشافه كيف حصل على
تصريح الدخول الى امور لا يحتاج نطلع
عليها ضمن النطاق عمله
المتحدث باسم البنتاجون قال ان هذه جريمه
متعمده اليس هذا استباق لحكم القضاء
هذا هذا نقطه مهمه
انا لا استطيع احكام على هذا الشاب الا
اذا حصل على محامي وظهر امام قاضي
وظهرت نتائج تحقيق وبالتالي كان من السابق
لاوانه اصدار حكم على هذا الشاب لقد
لقد ادخل السجن ووجهت اليه تهام وهو في
مراحل الاولى محاوله الدفاع عن نفسه هو
بريء الى ان تثبت اذانته حسب القانون ودنا
علينا نعمل نسمح للنظام بعمل لو كنت انا
مسؤولا رسميا
بالحذر قبل ان اصدر اي احكام خاصه في هذه
المرحله المبكره شكرا جزيلا لكم من باريس
وعاقب القاء القبض على تيشيرا وتوجيه
التهم له اي طريق سيسلكه المسار القانوني
في هذه القضيه
يصل التحقيق بقضيه التسريبات الى منتهى او
يقترب من الحل على حد وصف الرئيس بايدن
بمشهد درامي تلقي فيه قوات فيدراليه مدججه
بالسلاح القبض على عسكري يافع في مقتبل
العمر امام منزل عائلته التي عرفت بتاريخ
يمتد لعقود من الخدمه العسكريه
تنتقل كاميرات الصحافه سريعا كما العائله
الى ابواب قاعات المحكمه هناك حيث يمثل
المتهم الشاب جاك تشيره وتنتقل القضيه الى
سؤال جديد ما هي اجراءات المحاكمه وما
الذي قد تفضي اليه
يقضي القانون الامريكي بان يوقع كل شخص
يملك تصريحا امنيا اتفاقيه عدم افشاء
المعلومات وفقا للقانون الامريكي فان خرق
هذه الاتفاقيه هو عمل اجرامي وهو ما تم
اعتقال تيشيرا بناء عليه وفقا للمدعي
العام سيتهم تيشيرا بجريمه التجسس
والاحتفاظ بمعلومات سريه ونقلها ومشاركتها
يمكن ان يدان مرتكب هذه الجريمه بعقوبه
تصل الى السجن لعشر سنوات لكن الحكم الذي
قد يواجهه تيشيرا قد يكون اكبر اذ سيعتمد
على عدد التهم التي سيدان بها وما اذا كان
سيتم تقديم هذه التهم على التوالي او
بالتزامن على سبيل المثال اذا اتهمت شيره
بتسريب معلومات ليس لديه تصريح امني
بالوصول اليها فستكون احددتهم هي الوصول
الى معلومات بغير تصريح كذلك تعتمد التهم
على من شاركت شيرى المعلومات معهم مشاركه
معلومات سريه مع رعايا اجانب هي تهمه اخرى
قد يواجهها ويدان بها وهي تختلف عن تهمه
تسريب المعلومات لتحقيق مكاسب شخصيه او
توقع خدمه منها في قضيه مشابهه هي قضيه
ويكيليكس الشهيره حكم على الجندي الامريكي
برادلي مانينج الذي ادين بالتسريب بالسجن
35 عاما لكن الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما
قام بتخفيف العقوبه لاحقا
[موسيقى]
اعرب الرئيس الصيني شي جن بنك خلال
استقباله نظيره البرازيليه اعرب عن
استعداد بلاده للعمل مع البرازيل لتطوير
شراكه استراتيجيه طويله الامد كما اكد
الشي على ضروره تعزيز التعاون الثنائي في
مجالات الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه الرئيس
البرازيلي كان بدا جولته في شنغهاي لحضور
حفل تنصيب الرئيسه البرازيليه السابقه
على راس بنك بريكس حيث يوجد مقره ومن هناك
وجه انتقادات حاده واتهامات الى صندوق
النقد الدولي بانه يخنق اقتصادات دول مثل
الارجنتين على حد تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
التقارب الصيني البرازيلي تحت مظله مجموعه
بريكس ياتي في توقيت تتعالى فيه اصوات من
اجل عالم متعدد الاقطاب وبشكل رئيسي من
روسيا والصين ومنذ الحرب في اوكرانيا بدات
تقتل بريكسا الاقتصادي ياخذ ابعادا
جيوسياسيه ويثير بشكل اكبر مخاوف مجموعه
السبعه في البدايه كان اسمها بريك وهي
الاحرف الاولى باللاتينيه للدول الاعضاء
عند التاسيس عام 2006 وهي البرازيل وروسيا
والهند والصين تتميز الدول الاعضاء بانها
من الدول الناميه الصناعيه التي تتمتع
باقتصادات كبيره وصاعده وقد عقدت اول
مؤتمر لها في مدينه
الروسيه عام 2009 في 2010 وبعد انضمام
جنوب افريقيا الى المجموعه صار الاسم هو
في عام 2014 دشنت مجموعه بنك التنميه
الجديد براس مال مبدئي قدره 50 مليار
دولار كبديل للبنك ولصندوق النقد الدوليين
وفي مارس اذار الماضي كشفت جنوب افريقيا
عن تلقي 12 رساله من دول ابدت رغبتها في
التعاون مع المجموعه من ضمنها السعوديه
الامارات مصر والجزائر والارجنتين
والمكسيك ونيجيريا بعد سنوات مما تراه بعض
الدول اساءه لاستخدام وضع الدولار
الامريكي كعمله احتياط تتحد العديد من
الدول الاقتصاديا واكثرها اقتضاضا بالسكان
لاطلاق بديل للدولار الامريكي لاستخدامه
في التجاره العالميه وهذا ما تناقشه منظمه
البريكس بشكل ملح منذ الحرب في اوكرانيا
يعيش في الدول الخمس نصف سكان العالم
ويبلغ مجموع احتياطي النقد الاجنبي لدول
المنظمه اربعه دولار مع مرور الاعوام
اكتتبت مصر والامارات
2021 في اسهم بنك التنميه الذي اسسته
مجموعه دول باستثمارات بلغت عشره مليار
دولار وفي الوقت الذي حققت فيه الصين نموا
في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بما يقرب من 18
تريليون دولار عام 2021 فان الدول الاخرى
وهي البرازيل وجنوب افريقيا وروسيا قد
عانت من ركود وقد كشفت الارقام الاخيره عن
تفوق مجموعه بريكس لاول مره على دول
مجموعه السبع الاكثر تقدما في العالم وذلك
بعد ان بلغت مساهمه بريكس واحدا وثلاثين
ونصف بالمئه من الاقتصاد العالمي مقابل
30.7%
للقوه السبعه الصناعيه ينضم الينا الان او
بالاحرى تنضم الينا الان من لندن السيده
فيكي برايس كبيره المستشارين الاقتصاديين
في مركز ابحاث الاقتصاد والاعمال اهلا
وسهلا بك سيدي برايس هل من السهل ان تفرض
نفسها الان
اقتصاديا في هذا العالم
طبعا جزء مهم جدا الاقتصاد العالمي وتزداد
حصتهم في التجاره العالميه وما هو مؤكد
الدولار الامريكي ما زال هو المهيمن في
الصفقات التجاريه العالميه وما زال هو
المهيمن في الديون السياديه الدوليه
واسواق الدوليه
وايضا في اسواق القروض العالميه رغم انه
ليس هناك اي سكان
امريكان
يشاركون في اما الاقراضي او استلام هذه
القروض وبالتالي هذا جزء مهم جدا من
التجاره العالميه والاسواق العالميه
الدولار الامريكي ومن الصعب جدا ابتعاد
عنه كما تحاول بعض كما بدات تدرك بعض
الدول حاليا بعض الدول تبدو متفائله
وتراها بديلا عن الهيمنه الامريكيه كما
تقول وصندوق الن قد الدولي وكذا هل هذا
التفاؤل
متسرع ربما
انه ليس هناك اي شك بانه ما يحصل حاليا هو
اتحول وتغيير في طريقه
ترتيب الجغرافيا السياسيه في العالم ربما
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا نشادو ان عدد من
الدول التي تريد ان تواصل التعامل التجاري
مع روسيا وكذلك مع الصين بدات هذه الدول
تفكر انه ربما يمكن ان يتعاملوا بالتجاريا
اما باستخدام
عمله عالميه اخرى مختلفه تماما يمكن
تطويرها وضعها او يمكن ان يتعاملوا
بعملاتهم المحليه مباشره وهذا ما تامل ان
تفعله برازيل مع الصين مثلا مما لا شك فيه
ايضا
انه في اوروبا
اليورو يعتبر من قبل الاوروبيين على انه
ربما
عمله تجاريه
لاحتياط بديل عن الدولار واذا نرى في
مناطق مختلفه لعلم هناك قلق انه لو كان
اعتماد مبالغ فيه على عمله واحده فتلك
العمله مثلا لو زادت قيمتها كما يحصل حتى
مؤخرا مع الدولار الامريكي بسبب نسب
الفوائد المرتفعه فان ذلك كل الموقف
الاقتراضي والديون في الدول الاخرى سيد
سوءا وبالتالي ولذلك تحاول بعض الدول
الابتعاد عنها وفتك ارتباطها بالدولار
وبالتالي قد يكون السهم لبعض الدول التي
تجد نفس موقف صعب هل ان هذا واقعي على
المديان القصير والمتوسط هذا امر مختلف
اذا نظرنا بكل تفاؤل لهؤلاء الذين يتوقعون
تراجع الدولار مقابل العملات الاخرى كم
يستغرق من الوقت
يمكن بالتاكيد ان نبدا
بدراع حاله موجوده حاليا باستخدام عمل
احتياطيه اخرى بديله عن الدولاب وذلك
بالقيام كثير صفقات تجاريه التي تجاوز
الدولار تماما وهذا ممكن ولكن نظرا لان
الكثير من التجاره اننا لا تحدثت عن حوالي
نصف التجاره عالميه يهيمن عليها الدولار
حاليا وان الكثير من السلع التي نعرفها
جميعا تسعر بالدولار في الاسواق الدوليه
عندما يجري تبادلها شرائها او بيعها
وبالتالي يتطلب الامر بعض الوقت والسؤال
هو هل يمكن ان نجد عمله قابله للاعتماد
عليها ولان هناك مصرف مركزي كبير خلفها
وهناك سوق كبير لها وهناك ما يكفي من
السيول النقديه فيها ولن هذه العمله قابله
تحويل بسهوله وهل تقبل في اسواق البورصه
العالميه هناك الكثير من البدائل كانت
موجوده لكنها قد لا تستفيد من هذه الشروط
والظروف
شكرا جزيلا لك السيده فيكي برايس كنت معنا
من لندن
بهذا نصل الى نهايه جولتنا الاخباريه حصد
الليله تقبل الله صيامكم وقيامكم تصبحون
على خير
[موسيقى]